♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
OOH, OOH. WA-HA-HA.
ELIJAH, YOU ARE SCARING
THE BEJESUS OUT OF ME.
WHO DOES NOT LOVE THIS GAME?
IT IS A CLASSIC.
THE RULES ARE PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
WITH ONE HAND ONLY, YOU REMOVE
A BRICK FROM A LOWER LEVEL
AND PLACE IT ON TOP.
Adam:
OH, YEAH.
AS YOU GO, OF COURSE, THAT TOWER
GETS TALLER AND TALLER
AND LESS STABLE AND, EVENTUALLY,
USUALLY CRASHES DOWN.
ELIJAH,
ARE YOU READY?
NO.
YES.
BUT THERE IS ONE MYTHICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE MOVE IN JENGA,
AND THAT IS IN
A LATE-STAGE GAME,
IF THE WHOLE TOWER RESTS
ON A SINGLE BRICK,
THE MYTH IS THAT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE
TO REMOVE THAT BRICK
WITHOUT THE WHOLE TOWER
CRASHING DOWN.
OH!
I THINK THAT'S A TESTABLE
PROPOSITION.
Valerie: I WAS THINKING
A PNEUMATIC ACTUATOR,
WHICH I ACTUALLY GOT
FROM MY ROBOTICS EXPERIENCE.
I WAS LIKE, "OH. YOU WANT
TO PUSH SOMETHING OUT
THAT'S FAST
AND THAT'S STRONG?"
I WAS LIKE, "OH, YEAH.
PNEUMATIC ACTUATOR, PERFECT."
Narrator: WITH AN AIR-POWERED
PISTON MOUNTED
TO THE BASE OF A SWING ARM,
THE SPEED IS MAXIMIZED,
AND THE BLOCK IS KNOCKED OUT...
IN THEORY.
NOW I'M EXCITED.
Narrator:
WITH THE AIR TANK CONNECTED,
VALERIE IS READY FOR
A LOW-PRESSURE PROOF OF CONCEPT.
THREE, TWO, ONE.
THAT WAS AWESOME.
[ SCREECHING ]
♪♪
OKAY. THAT'S A PRECARIOUS
LATE-STAGE JENGA GAME.
WILL HER AIR-POWERED PISTON
PULL OFF THE IMPOSSIBLE?
THE WAITING IS OVER.
I'M GOING TO CHARGE THE TANK.
OKAY.
Narrator:
WITH THE AIR PRESSURE SET
TO ITS MAXIMUM RATING...
OKAY.
WE'RE AT 120 PSI.
IT IS YOUR EXPERIMENT.
COUNT IT IN.
Narrator:
...AND VALERIE'S NERVES
EQUALLY HIGHLY CHARGED...
OH, MY GOD.
I JUST GOT BUTTERFLIES
IN MY STOMACH, NO LIE.
I'M LIKE, "OH, MY GOD.
OKAY. OKAY."
Narrator: ...THIS IS THE MYTH'S
LAST CHANCE.
THIS IS PNEUMATIC ACTUATOR TEST.
THREE, TWO, ONE.
-THAT WAS REALLY CLOSE.
-OH!
♪♪
THAT WAS AMAZING.
THAT WAS SO MUCH CLOSER THAN
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE AFTER...
-THAT WAS AWESOME.
-...SEEING THE PREVIOUS TEST.
Narrator:
THREE OUT OF THREE FAILURES,
BUT THEY'RE NOT CALLING IT YET.
THE TEAM THINKS THERE'S AN ISSUE
WITH THE SUPERSIZED BLOCKS.
OUR THOUGHT PROCESS WAS THAT IF
WE MADE THIS HUGE JENGA TOWER,
THEN WE COULD HAVE
BIGGER BLOCKS,
WHICH WOULD MEAN THAT THERE'S
A LARGER THING TO GRAB
SO IT WOULD BE EASIER
TO YANK IT OUT FROM THE BOTTOM.
BUT WHAT WE DIDN'T ACCOUNT FOR
IS THE AMOUNT OF WEIGHT
THAT WOULD BE PRESSING DOWN
ON IT
WOULD A LOT MORE
THAN ACTUAL GAME PLAY.
Adam:
IN SCALING UP OUR JENGA BRICKS,
AS COOL AS THAT WAS,
WE MESSED UP THE PHYSICS.
SEE?
WHEN YOU SCALE SOMETHING UP
BY LENGTH, WIDTH, AND HEIGHT,
YOU ALSO HAVE TO
COMMENSURABLY SCALE ITS WEIGHT,
AND THUS, TO FINALLY TEST
THEIR RIGS AND CALL THIS MYTH,
THEY'RE GOING BACK
TO THE NORMAL-SIZE JENGA.
Narrator:
AND WITH THEIR RIGS REMODIFIED
FOR STANDARD-SIZE BLOCKS,
THEY'RE READY.
Elijah: WAIT. WAIT. WHERE'S THAT
THING THAT I HAD
THAT I WAS GOING TO...
-ELIJAH!
-NO!
OKAY. SORRY.
THAT WAS COMPLETELY MY FAULT.
Narrator:
ALMOST READY TO GO AGAIN.
I'M GOING TO TWIST
A LITTLE BIT...
[BLEEP]
-WAIT.
DID YOU CURSE?
-THAT'S ME CURSING.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I CURSED
ON CAMERA.
I'VE BEEN SO GOOD
THIS WHOLE TIME.
NO, HE WASN'T.
I HEARD HIM ONCE BEFORE.
-WHAT DID HE SAY?
Narrator:
THIRD TIME IS A CHARM.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
WE ARE IN.
EVERYBODY FOCUS.
I'M GOING TO HAVE GRAY HAIRS
AT THE END OF THIS.
I THINK WE ALL ARE.
I ALREADY HAD A GRAY HAIR
AFTER FIRST GRADE.
AH.
THAT IS AWESOME.
Narrator:
QUESTION IS, "WILL IT WORK?"
ARE YOU READY, ELIJAH?
FINAL SMALL-SCALE BUNGEE TEST,
JENGA TOWER
IN THREE, TWO, ONE.
-OH!
-THAT WAS VERY, VERY GOOD.
THAT WAS INCREDIBLE!
ONE.
OH!
DUDE, THAT WAS A LOT
MORE SUCCESSFUL.
I THINK WE'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK
GOING TO THE SMALL-SCALE JENGA.
PUNCH IN, BUDDY.
YEAH!
♪♪
Narrator:
ALLIE IS NEXT.
THE BIKE IS ATTACHED TO THE
FISHING LINE AND CALIPERS,
THE TOWER CONSTRUCTED,
A NICKNAME BESTOWED...
Allie: YOU BETTER NOT
BE WRITING, "KICK ME."
OH, GOSH, NO.
I'M GIVING YOU
A NICKNAME HERE.
I'M CALLING YOU CRASH.
-OKAY.
I HOPE I DON'T,
THOUGH.
IT'S A NICKNAME,
NOT A PROPHECY.
Narrator:
AND LAUNCH PROCEDURE INITIATED.
JENGA BIKE TEST FINAL
IN THREE...
TWO...
ONE.
♪♪
[ LAUGHS ]
I SEE NO TOWER.
TOTALLY DESTROYED.
A PERFECT FAILURE.
[ ADAM LAUGHS ]
♪♪
Allie: THAT WAS REALLY,
REALLY FUN, ACTUALLY.
I LIKE TO THINK OF MYSELF
AS VERY COMPETITIVE,
BUT I TRY NOT TO LET IT
GET IN THE WAY OF
JUST IMPORTANT THINGS LIKE THIS.
Narrator:
VALERIE IS UP LAST.
WILL THIS JENGA JOURNEY
END IN A BLOCK PARTY,
OR WILL THEY CRASH AND LEARN?
THIS IS PNEUMATIC ACTUATOR
TEST,
120 PSI, FINAL TEST
IN THREE...
TWO...
ONE.
WHOA!
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT WAS AWESOME!
[ LAUGHING ]
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT WAS AMAZING.
ONE.
♪♪
AMAZING!
THAT WAS AWESOME.
-AMAZING.
-YEAH!
-ONE.
-YOU COULDN'T EVEN SEE THAT.
IT WAS JUST LIKE,
IT WAS GONE.
THAT'S CRA--
IT'S A SAMURAI JENGA.
THAT'S WHAT YOU INVENTED,
A BRAND-NEW GAME.
RIGHT.
AMAZING.
WELL DONE.
THANK YOU.
♪ I DID THE IMPOSSIBLE
JENGA BLOCK ♪
OH, MY GOD.
IT WORKED!
IT WAS SO COOL.
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY PSI,
AND THIS THING IS STANDING.
MY PNEUMATIC ACTUATOR PUSHED OUT
THE IMPOSSIBLE JENGA BLOCK,
WHICH WAS JUST AMAZING.
Narrator:
YEP. WITH AN IMPACT VELOCITY
OF 75 MILES PER HOUR,
THERE'S LITTLE TIME
FOR FRICTION,
AND THE TOWER STAYS STANDING.
AT THIS POINT, YOU MIGHT BE
WONDERING,
I CAN HEAR YOU THINKING,
"I WONDER HOW MUCH OF THOSE
MECHANICAL SOLUTIONS
THE KIDS CAME UP
WITH THEMSELVES,"
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
THEY DID, AND IT TOTALLY WORKED.
THE IMPOSSIBLE JENGA MOVE
IS, IN FACT, POSSIBLE.
Valerie: ONE.
WHOA!
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT WAS AWESOME.